the Joe Rogan experience when you and
him started going after it you and John
Jones started going after an Instagram I
was like oh no let it be known he
started it yes
he started it why had he started no it
was I thinks I'm the freshman I'm the
guy that he wishes he was and he's a fan
trust me he's a fan he's my biggest fan
and I think he sees himself you know
like man I could have been that cool you
know fighting [ __ ] all this up and he
sees me like a new freshman getting all
the shine getting all the hype but he's
still the champ yes and he's still
undefeated normally really how much it
was [ __ ] man how about talking Ryan
he was just try it was just trying you
know I don't mean Matt Hamels probably
broke yeah you know I'm saying yeah he's
undefeated he's a guy laughing I first
watched him fight because I was a fan it
was UFC 94 Penn vs. GSP - and he fought
Stefan Stefan yeah and just hit him with
some stuff and with that spinning elbow
hit him was that a double overwhelming
lateral draw I'm sure it's this guy you
know and you know the comparisons were
always gonna be there like with him and
this is silver with wrestling then when
I came on the scene AUSA's Jones a
better striking I'm like and I said it
from the get-go I will outgrow those
those comparisons I was like oh they're
gonna forget about this so now they're
not comparing us they're saying ooh
let's watch them fight yeah I like the
fight I said this is July um after the I
think it was the MMA Awards I was in my
hotel room and allegedly I might have
been stoned
but I looked allegedly I was [ __ ]
stoned and I was looking across like a
sea rate of stadium being built and I
was like for whatever reason just
decided that's where it's gonna happen
it's such a [ __ ] crazy fight the way
it's gonna happen it's just boom let him
go to heavy weight I'll drag him back
down I'll drag him back down and I said
like 20 21 is the time cuz I don't want
to disrespect the game I'm not gonna
hold up the division the division be
held up long enough by Robert [ __ ]
means sick and being injured and you
know romera not making winter all this
[ __ ] I'm like let me do what silver did
which was honor the [ __ ] code and
actually be a champion and defend the
belt so I'm gonna do that I've done that
once
against Robert Whittaker the winterim
champs I'm gonna do it again his killers
out the Ivysaur cannoneer in the weekend
and he's the [ __ ] beautiful dude man
such a nice guy he's a very what's up
brother I was a killer exactly he's the
dark horse he's the darkness everyone
thinks Romero is everyone things cost
there's the one not he is the God like
I'm stalking him I've been watching the
men he's another guy that's made it
shift mmm over the last year and a half
or so Jerrod's made his shift where he's
just become more and more serious more
and more dangerous and you watching them
when he took out Anderson so when he
[ __ ] his leg up Jesus like yeah he's
on on a mission it's not a mission I see
him and I'm not slipping
they'll never met me slipping unless I
slip them in a rhythm he's got fantastic
genetics too and there's a tank see I
saw when he was fighting this guy a
heavyweight it was heavyweight yeah you
walked them down with his hands down
yeah heavyweight yeah he's gonna shred
it yeah it's crazy back go all the way
from heavyweight to 185 that's [ __ ]
phenomenal I think Maura Nelson should
have done it to be honest
[Applause]